what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today today's disney
plus day here it's been kind of
mellow on the news i don't know it's
exciting for some people not exciting
for others then i had people tell me
that there's some marvel announcements
coming out and i was on youtube and i
was like i don't see any trailers what
are you guys talking about and they're
like just go to marvel's twitter page
and there's a bunch of announcements
here what i did was all right so we can
give a proper reaction i just opened up
the marvel twitter page and i just
scrolled down and like really fast
and now we're just gonna start scrolling
up and see the order of announcements to
see what has come through here because
it's one of those they announced a bunch
of shows and such because yeah i heard
there was like some sizzle reel on on
the app but i was trying to look it up
and but it wasn't i looked on that
computer i looked at my phone and it
wasn't loading on my account for some
reason it wasn't even appearing at all
as an option and this is the best way we
can do it right now in a limited amount
of time all right guys so actually while
filming this i got a call from warren
from cosmic wonder saying that people
who have been using the footage have
been getting their videos blocked from
that sizzle reel that we did not
discover until after we were done
shooting this video so we're gonna try
to put up a video covering the new stuff
in there
if we succeed it'll be up on the channel
let's do this
we got
are they saying what i think they're
saying an animated original series no
way oh good
hey man it's about time what it's about
time what yes dude that's awesome that
mean people do you mean to tell me i
chose this beatty on the right day
man and i didn't bring my wolverine
shirt in on the right day
but yeah people have been like
scrambling for more like animated series
like wait no it's really they're saying
they're reviving the series is that is
that what i'm understanding it says an
animated original series is that what
i'm so they're reviving the 97 series
they must be picking it back up holy
[ __ ]
that is nuts to me i never expected that
news
no i didn't i didn't even hear rumors
about that did you i didn't even hear
rumors no just people that's a great
show
preferred over the spider-man one from
the 90s and revisiting it recently i was
like i didn't realize just how mature
this show was dude why is this news not
am i trending they better drop on
saturday holy [ __ ] i can't
look at it i don't understand how it
could get better than that
okay
downhill from here so then we got moon
knight
cool she-hulk she-hulk
okay oh so this is like official logo
for she-hulk yeah that's cool it's a
cool little logo looking over
you know what's going on there guys
alright miss marvel
what if season what is season two we
knew that was coming all right could
have at least tried something a little
special with her poster the echo series
awesome echo who makes her debut in the
hawkeye show
deaf character if i'm not mistaken and
she has abilities similar to task master
marvel really
spider-man freshman year ooh an animated
original series
okay this is an animated one
oh man i was kind of hoping they'd bring
back spectacular spider-man oh that's a
bummer
tweeting them start replying start quote
quote retweeting and be like bring it
back i mean i'll of course give it a
chance but spectacular spider-man if you
guys haven't seen that watch it do
yourselves a favor watch it it's
probably my favorite animated spider-man
property i've ever seen yes i'm gonna
upset some people i like it more than
into the spider verse
i'm not saying the animation is better
like the animation does not get better
inspired verse but in terms of the story
and josh keenan as peter parker was
absolutely perfect and then
when something with the rights started
happening i think it was around the
merger time i forget the logistics of
what happened but spectacular spider-man
just
stopped
like she said edit on a great
cliffhanger no real conclusion and i
thought they did the clone wars thing or
they're like we're researching it like
the way how they just do with x-men yeah
i thought that's what they were gonna do
don't worry wait another decade and then
they'll bring back spectacular spiders
damn but still spider-man freshman year
i wonder if it's gonna be a college show
though instead of a high school show
because usually it's he's in high school
he's in a lot of high schools he's a
freshman in grad school yeah
even for medical school yeah peter's
becoming a doctor he's passing the bar
now he's like 40 years old
and they haven't confirmed if it's peter
parker i'm assuming it's peter parker it
might be tom holland and i doubt it uh
that'd be weird
[Laughter]
yeah but it makes sense because they
need this to be in continuity right yeah
uh so maybe perhaps it'll be
uh
i remember the guy who voiced the what
if peter parker but it could be that one
yeah he did he did a really good time
holland a logo for i am groot
logo for iron heart
agatha house of heartness
agatha's getting her own show yeah
who wouldn't say about me that the one
i'm most excited about is the revival i
mean i'm happy for catherine hahn she's
a spectacular actress yeah yeah and
there is a lot to explore with agatha's
backstory because all we saw was just
the origin of like in being introduced
when she's about to be burnt it's not
burnt but uh yeah put to death yeah yeah
yeah when she's being confronted by the
rest of the coven and they're trying to
like you know zap her over power and all
that but yeah i mean especially if
marvel is gonna continue expanding their
you know uh magical mystical world you
know i think this could be a good
opportunity for that it would be cool if
they did kind of one of those shows
where they you see the backstory sort of
like a better call saul
where do you see the backstory and then
you're also going to go to the
the present with her or like your cast
wanda vision see what she was doing
during one division when we weren't
looking at her and then go past that i
like that idea yeah marvel's zombies
zombies show okay
dang
that's great i mean that's really
exciting to me because i thought there
was a lot of potential in the what-if
episode and it while it wasn't my
favorite episode it was one that i think
you could easily expand upon and that
people have like a cult and love for and
i mean i expect that they will take the
direction set forth by the what-if
episode which is a bit different from
the comic but still i think this will be
something very fun and cheeky true out
of all of them yeah we were a little bit
let down by that zombies episode that
was in what if and we were also saying
that we don't think it needs to be hyper
violent in order for it to succeed would
really with a good zombie
property all it really needs to if you
don't want to go r-rated is have like a
lot of great tension and mood and
atmosphere and really capitalize on that
and a lot of the horror can be things
that conjure up in your own mind and so
there's a lot of ways to bring out a lot
of dread and the terrors of what's
happening to people you love watching
you know the character descent on a lot
of people like that's where a lot of the
great zombie horror comes from it's not
just from like eating people and stuff
it has to come from that yeah i think
there's a lot of potential to be having
marvel zombies and then okay secret
invasion
all right cool cool
oh
well i guess we'll film something for
that after this yeah
the mouse left oh why wasn't this
popping that's what i was exactly some
people didn't type in it wasn't popping
up
traffic that it broke okay cool we'll
have another video coming up but guys
subscribe which announcement are you
most excited for hit that like button
click that notification bell keep a
lookout for our next video well i'll see
you soon shortly
you